estos son los pasos para dibujar
estructuras de puntos de lewis digamos
que queremos dibujar la estructura de
puntos para la molécula de tetracloruro
de silicio lo primero que necesitamos es
contar el número total de electrones de
valencia para colocarlos en nuestra
estructura echemos un vistazo a la tabla
periódica esta es una versión modificada
de la tabla periódica del bloque t así
será más fácil identificar los grupos si
observan los elementos que tenemos en el
primer grupo como el hidrógeno litio y
sodio todos los elementos del primer
grupo tienen un electrón de valencia el
número de grupo corresponde al número de
electrones de valencia entonces el
hidrógeno tiene un electrón de valencia
ahora si pensamos en los periodos
recuerden que los periodos son las filas
horizontales de la tabla periódica
observen que el hidrógeno se encuentra
en el primer periodo así que tiene un
electrón de valencia y el helio tiene
dos electrones de valencia recuerden que
en el primer nivel de energía como
máximo se pueden tener dos electrones
por ejemplo al dibujar un nitrógeno
siempre estará rodeado por dos
electrones sólo tendrá un enlace
covalente y si analizamos el segundo
periodo el litio tiene un electrón de
valencia el berilio tiene dos boro tiene
tres el carbono tiene cuatro el
nitrógeno tiene cinco oxígeno tiene seis
flúor tiene siete y el neón tiene ocho
observen que hay más orbitales en el
segundo nivel de energía y podemos tener
como máximo ocho electrones de ahí que
hablemos de la regla del octeto por eso
elementos como el carbón nitrógeno
y flúor cumplen con la regla del octeto
y eso nos ayudará mucho cuando dibujemos
las estructuras ahora es posible que
algunos elementos del segundo periodo no
cumplan con la regla del octeto y pueden
tener menos de 8 electrones como es el
caso del boro pero no es posible que
tengan más de 8 electronics siempre
revisen que en sus estructuras ningún
elemento del segundo periodo tenga más
de 8 electrones ahora en el tercer
período
tenemos más orbitales disponibles
entonces en el primer nivel de energía
sólo tenemos un orbital s en el segundo
nivel
tenemos orbitales s&p y en el tercer
tenemos orbitales s&p y de estos
elementos pueden tener más de 8
electrones veremos algunos ejemplos en
este vídeo pero regresemos a nuestra
molécula de tetracloruro de silicio
si queremos saber el número total de
electrones de valencia
primero encontremos a los elementos en
nuestra tabla periódica aquí tenemos el
silicio que se encuentra en el grupo 4
así que un átomo de silicio tiene 4
electrones de valencia y por acá tenemos
al flúor que se encuentra en el grupo 7
así que por cada átomo de flúor tenemos
7 electrones de valencia entonces 7 por
4 tenemos 28 electrones de valencia en
el flúor y 28 más 4 nos da un total de
32 electrones de valencia ahora ya
sabemos cuál es el número total de
electrones de valencia y como no tenemos
ninguna carga no tenemos que
preocuparnos por eso entonces vamos con
el paso 2 hay que definir cuál es el
átomo central que será el átomo menos el
electrón negativo
y después hay que dibujar los enlaces
nosotros tenemos silicio y flúor que en
la tabla periódica aquí tenemos al flúor
y en este caso es el elemento más
electro negativo así que para el tetra
fluoruro de silicio nuestro átomo
central es el silicio porque es el menos
electro negativo de los dos entonces
tenemos al silicio que está unido a
cuatro átomos de flúor
hasta ahora ya dibujamos cuatro enlaces
covalentes y como cada enlace consiste
en dos electrones de valencia aquí
tenemos dos cuatro seis y
ya colocamos 8 electrones de valencia y
como en total teníamos 32 electrones 32
menos 8 nos falta colocar 24 electrones
regresemos a nuestros pasos ya sabemos
cuál es el átomo central y pusimos los
enlaces también ya restamos los
electrones que colocamos en los enlaces
del total de electrones que calculamos
en el paso 1 así que ahora en el paso 3
vamos a colocar los electrones restantes
en los átomos terminales en este caso
son los átomos de flúor entonces podemos
empezar por colocar los electrones en
los átomos de flúor
si regresamos a la tabla periódica el
flúor se encuentra en el segundo periodo
y cumple con la regla del octeto así que
cada átomo de flúor necesita estar
rodeado por 8 electrones
y como cada uno ya tiene 12 electrones a
su alrededor agreguemos 6 electrones más
a cada flúor le ponemos 6 electrones de
valencia y como colocamos 6 electrones a
cada uno de los 4 átomos de flúor 6 por
4 es igual a 24 hemos colocado todos los
electrones de valencia esta es nuestra
estructura final ya no tenemos que pasar
al paso 4 veamos otro ejemplo ahora
tenemos ch 2 of formaldehído entonces
primero vamos a calcular el número total
de electrones de valencia necesitamos
encontrar el carbono hidrógeno y oxígeno
en la tabla periódica observen que el
carbono se encuentra en el grupo 4 así
que tiene 4 electrones de valencia por
acá tenemos el hidrógeno en el grupo 1
un electrón de valencia y el oxígeno se
encuentra en el grupo 6 así que tiene 6
electrones de valencia entonces vamos a
calcular el número total de electrones
de valencia que colocaremos en nuestra
estructura de puntos tenemos un átomo de
carbono que tiene 4 electrones de
valencia después cada hidrógeno tiene un
electrón de valencia pero como tenemos
21 por dos y cada oxígeno tiene 6
electrones entonces 6 más cuatro más dos
es igual a 12 electrones de valencia
ahora regresemos a nuestros pasos ya
sabemos el número total de electrones de
valencia y como no tenemos cargas no
tenemos que preocuparnos por el resto
del paso 1
en el paso 2 hay que definir el átomo
central que corresponde al menos electro
negativo y recuerden que debemos ignorar
al hidrógeno así que para este ejemplo
el átomo central sin tomar en cuenta el
hidrógeno podría ser el carbono o el
oxígeno veamos la tabla periódica el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
carbón
entonces el carbono es el átomo central
está unido a dos hidrógenos y un oxígeno
ya colocamos 246 electrones de valencia
y como necesitamos colocar 12 y ya
colocamos 6
nos falta colocar 6 electrones de
valencia regresemos a nuestros pasos en
el paso 3 hay que colocar los electrones
restantes a los átomos terminales en
este caso nuestros átomos terminales son
los hidrógenos y el
y geno pero no podemos colocar más
electrones en el hidrógeno porque los
dos átomos ya están rodeados por dos
electrones entonces coloquemos los
electrones en el oxígeno que sigue la
regla del octeto y como ya está rodeado
por dos electrones solo le faltan seis
electrones de valencia ya colocamos
todos los electrones pero no hemos
terminado porque el carbono también debe
cumplir con la regla del octeto
regresemos a nuestros pasos en el paso 4
si el átomo central no ha completado su
octeto podemos ayudarlo creando enlaces
múltiples entonces podemos tomar uno de
estos pares de electrones libres y
moverlos hacia acá entonces nos queda el
carbono unido con un doble enlace a este
oxígeno
ahora tiene dos pares de electrones
libres y después tenemos a los
hidrógenos hacia abajo esta es la
estructura de puntos de louis para el
formaldehído y tenemos 8 electrones
alrededor del carbono 2 468 electrones
ya completó su octeto entonces tenemos 8
electrones alrededor del oxígeno 8
alrededor del carbono y cada hidrógeno
tiene 2 electrones están felices muy
bien hagamos uno más ahora tenemos el
catión penta fluoruro de xenón entonces
encontremos al xenón y el flúor en la
tabla periódica aquí tenemos al xenón
que se encuentra en el grupo 8 así que
tiene 8 electrones de valencia y por acá
tenemos al flúor que se encuentra en el
grupo 7
entonces el xenón tiene
8 electrones de valencia y cada átomo de
flúor tiene 7 electrones pero como
tenemos 5 átomos 7 por 5 es igual a 35 y
35 más 8 nos da 43 electrones de
valencia pero recuerden que esta
molécula es un cateo tiene una carga
positiva y eso significa que perdemos un
electrón entonces necesitamos restar un
electrón a 43 y nos quedan 42 electrones
de valencia en total regresemos a
nuestros pasos ya sabemos cuál es el
número total de electrones de valencia y
como en este caso tenemos una carga
positiva
por eso restamos un electrón
en el paso 2 hay que definir al átomo
central que será el menos electro
negativo entonces como el flúor es más
electro negativo nuestro átomo central
es el xenón vamos a escribir lo tenemos
al xenón unido a 5 átomos de flúor
hasta ahora ya colocamos 2 4 6 8 10
electrones de valencia y como
necesitamos colocar 42 en total sólo nos
faltan 32 electrones de valencia
observen que el xenón ya sobrepasó la
regla del octeto pero no hay problema
porque el xenón se encuentra después del
tercer periodo de la tabla periódica
ahora el siguiente paso es colocar los
electrones de valencia restantes en
nuestros átomos terminales los átomos de
flúor que como sabemos cumplen con la
regla del octeto y como cada átomo de
flúor ya tiene 2 electrones a su
alrededor
podemos agregar 6 electrones de valencia
entonces si agregamos 6 electrones de
valencia a 5 átomos de flúor 6 por 5 es
igual a 30 y solo nos faltan 2
electrones entonces regresemos a
nuestros pasos en el paso 4 si es
necesario como en este caso hay que
colocar los electrones sobrantes en el
átomo central y si el átomo central ya
tiene su octeto o lo excede como es
nuestro caso hemos terminado aunque hay
que revisar las cargas formales pero eso
lo veremos en otro vídeo entonces vamos
a colocar los dos electrones que faltan
en nuestro seno ya colocamos todos los
42 electrones de valencia y podemos
poner nuestra estructura entre corchetes
para señalar la carga positiva
este es nuestro ocasión de penta
fluoruro de xenón en los siguientes
vídeos
vemos más ejemplos de cómo dibujar
estructuras de puntos de lewis y cómo
predecir la geometría de las moléculas